[Música]
en directo a vamos a esta ciudad de
guatemala allí se encuentra nuestro
corresponsal para hablar de
centroamérica andrés suárez jaramillo y
con quien discutiremos sobre el salvador
porque hace un año el gobierno adoptó el
bitcoin como moneda de curso legal una
medida que ha sido defendida
constantemente por el presidente en allí
bukele pero que ha recibido críticas de
los expertos que dicen que no se ha
materializado la mayoría de las
expectativas
andrés muy buenas noches cuáles han sido
las fechas clave del primer año del
bitcoin como moneda legal en el salvador
andrés buenas noches debemos comenzar en
junio de 2021 porque fue el momento de
la conferencia del beat con en miami
cuando el presidente nayib ukulele
anunció al mundo ya los asistentes de
esta conferencia que el salvador sería
el primer país soberano en adoptar esta
cripto moneda como una moneda de curso
legal y tres vidas después de este 5 de
junio el 8 la asamblea legislativa que
está controlada por el gobierno de
mayoría oficialista lanzó ese decreto
legislativo para que el bit con fuera
una moneda legal la misma asamblea que
además le otorgó al gobierno más de 200
millones de dólares para que pudiera
invertir y después de ese junio saltamos
a septiembre hace un año exactamente
cuando buque le compró con este dinero
las primeras 400 monedas de bitcoin hace
un año el 7 de septiembre el bitcoin
entra a ser legal pero también se da la
gran marcha de manifestantes en contra
de esta adopción forzada del bitcoin sin
embargo las cosas pareciera que le
estuvieran saliendo bien a nadie bukele
porque noviembre de 2021 después 13 años
de estar de esta cripto moneda fuera
lanzada al mundo llegó a su máximo
histórico una moneda de bitcoin 69 mil
dólares una dicha que cayó en desdicha
en junio de este año con el denominado
cripto invierno porque ya haber estado
en 69 mil dólares
por debajo de los 20 mil dólares hoy en
día el salvador presenta 55% en pérdidas
de lo invertido en esta cripto moneda
andrés es una de las grandes preguntas
es actualmente que tanto usan los
salvadoreños el bitcoin y qué proyectos
tiene el gobierno de bukele relacionado
con este cripto activo
la respuesta es muy poco los
salvadoreños no están invirtiendo en
bitcoin por dos razones la primera es
porque de acuerdo con la asociación
nacional de empresa privada salvadoreña
el bitcoin no ha representado para la
población para la ciudadanía un
beneficio mayor de usar hoja frente al
dólar en comparativo frente al dólar por
ejemplo al principio a todos los
salvadoreños se les dio la oportunidad
de descargar el chivo boleto una
billetera digital una aplicación que
tienen en sus celulares y que se les dio
un incentivo de 30 dólares muchos
salvadoreños hicieron uso de este
incentivo económico pero después dejaron
de usar el chivo wallet ahora quienes
han comprado bitcoins quienes sí tienen
bitcoins en este momento los tienen
congelados porque desde que se desplomó
la cripto moneda no han querido usarlos
y es justamente lo que está diciendo el
ministro de hacienda alejandro celaya
que le pide a los salvadoreños calma
paciencia porque se asegura que la
cripto moneda volverá a subir volverá a
red qué es un panorama que desmiente el
fondo monetario internacional entre
tanto están congelados los proyectos de
emisión de bonos soberanos por más de
mil millones de dólares que ha prometido
el gobierno en allí bukele para la
construcción de dos mega proyectos uno
es la bit coin city que es una ciudad
del futuro una ciudad moderna construida
con las ganancias del bitcoin además y
también el nuevo aeropuerto del
pacífico' proyectos ambiciosos de hanjin
bukele con los que espera poner al
salvador en la palestra del mundo
cosmopolita pero que por ahora están
congelados por cuenta de un bitcoin por
debajo de los 20 mil dólares